الجيش السوداني يؤكد ان اتفاق التهدئه ليس
سياسيا السعوديه تنطلق الى الفضاء اليوم
الجيش الاوكراني ينفذ هجوما مرتدا على
بخموت
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
ونبدا اخبارنا من السودان والهدنه المعلنه
هناك ففي ظل تاكيدا على اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار قال جيش السوداني ان الاتفاق مع
قوات الدعم السريع ينحصر على الجوانب
الفنيه والعسكريه ولا يتضمن المسائل
السياسيه بيان للجيش اوضح ان القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقعت في جده على اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار لمده سبعه ايام يدخل حيز
التنفيذ اعتبارا من مساء الاثنين وينحصر
على الجوانب العسكريه والفنيه الخاصه
بترتيبات وقف اطلاق النار المؤقت واجراءات
حريه التنقل المدني
حدث تاريخيه تشهده السعوديه في مجال
الفضاء حيث اعلنت هيئه الفضاء في المملكه
عن الانتهاء من الاستعدادات قبل انطلاق
رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علي القرني وريان
برناوي ضمن طاقم من مهمه العلميه للتوجه
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه ضمن المهمه التي
او المهمه اي اكس 2 التي تضم ايضا رايي
فضاء امريكيين الهيئه اكدت في وقت سابق ان
هذه الرحله تاتي ضمن برنامج المملكه لرواد
الفضاء الذي تم اطلاقه في سبتمبر من العام
الفائت وتتضمن اجراء اربعه عشره تجربه
بحثيه علميه رائده
رغم تاكيد الجانب الروسي تصر كياف على
بقاء قوتها في بخموت نافيه سقوطها بشكل
كامل بيد القوات الروسيه المتمثله بمجموعه
فاغنر نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هن
مليار قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه نفذت
هجوما مرتدا على القوات الروسيه وطوقت
بشكل جزئي مدينه بخموت المحاصره مؤكده ان
قوات بلادها لا تزال تسيطر على قطاع
بالمدينه في المقابل هنا الرئيس
الروسيبلاديمير بوتين مجموعه فاجنر والجيش
الروسي على ما وصفه بانه تحرير مدينه
في انجاز علمي جديده تمكن علماء من جامعه
ستانفورد الامريكيه من ابتكار جلد
الكتروني اصطناعي يحاكي الخصائص الفريده
للجلد الحقيقي وتم تصميم هذا الجلد من
مواد ناعمه ومرنه تحاكي الحواس كما يمكنه
التواصل مباشره مع الدماغ هذا النظام
يعتبر الاول الذي يجمع بين الاستشعار
وجميع الميزات الكهربائيه والميكانيكيه في
جلد الانسان بشكل ناعم ومتين ويعمل الجذب
الالكتروني الجديد بجهد خمسه فولت فقط
ويمكنه اكتشاف منبهات مشابهه للبشره
الحقيقيه
نختم من عالم الفن تحديدا من مدينه
نيويورك التي شهدت بيع جيتار محطم للفنان
وهو احد اعضاء الفرقه الموسيقيه العالميه
نيرفانا والذي سبق وان حطمه على احد
المسارح الجيتار دعا مقابل 600 الف دولار
وفقا لما اعلنت دار جوليانز للمزادات
والتي اعلنت ان الجيتار اعيد جمع اجزائه
لكن العزف عليه لم يعد ممكنا كان كوبين
مدمنا على المخدرات ويعاني اكتئابا كما ان
علاقته مع زوجته كانت مضطربه ما ادى الى
انتحاره في ابريل من عام 94 من القرن
الماضي